Speaker 1: I want to go back now to this viral
story of a ten year old in Ohio impregnated
after being raped and subsequently going to
Indiana for an abortion because of Ohio's
strict abortion laws.
Now, we covered the story as it was reported
a week or two ago.
It was either early last week or late the
previous week.
And it's an incredibly disturbing story.
Not surprisingly, many on the right said it
was just a made up story.
And we're going to get to that in the second
part of the segment.
But that's not where I want to start.
Where I want to start is the follow up to
the story, which is that an arrest has now
been made of the alleged perpetrator.
And this is part of what has now shifted the
narrative from the American right on the story,
which we will get to in due time.
So here's the latest.
The Columbus Dispatch reporting arrest made
in rape of Ohio girl that led to Indiana abortion
drawing international attention.
Now, part of the reason why it drew international
attention, national and international, was
that this happened in the immediate aftermath
of the Supreme Court announcing that Roe v
Wade is no more, that the fundamental right
to an abortion in most cases in the country
is no more.
And people like South Dakota Governor Kristi
Noem, the Mississippi House speaker, whose
name I forget and others were asked, what
about cases where a kid is raped and impregnated?
12 year old was the example that was often
given.
Would you feel comfortable forcing them to
carry a child to term?
And one of the reactions was These are imaginary
situations.
These are mere hypotheticals.
We don't deal in hypothetical.
And very quickly, we had a real story, and
that was much of why the story became viral
in the way that it did.
Well, the follow up is, is the following.
A Columbus man has been charged with impregnating
a ten year old Ohio girl who's traveled to
Indiana to seek an abortion, led to international
attention following the Supreme Court overturning
Roe v Wade and the activation of Ohio's abortion
law.
Gersson Fuentes, 27 years old, was arrested
Tuesday after police say he confessed to raping
the child on at least two occasions.
He's since been charged with rape, a felony
in the first degree in Ohio.
Columbus police were made aware of the girl's
pregnancy through a referral by, frankly,
Franklin County Children's Services made by
her mother on June 22nd.
On June 30, the girl underwent a medical abortion
in Indianapolis.
So first and foremost, the Indiana abortion
part was a real part of the story.
The right was desperate to say, that's fake,
that's fake.
And let's find whatever doctors are committing
crimes here.
It was a real part of the story hewn.
The detective also testified that DNA from
the clinic in Indianapolis is being tested
against samples from Fuentes, as well as the
child's siblings, to confirm contribution
to the aborted fetus, as you can imagine.
If that is confirmed, this will be an open
and shut case.
Now, one other interesting element here that
I will discuss, Franklin County Municipal
Court Judge Cynthia Ebner said the case did
not warrant Fuentes, who is believed to be
an undocumented immigrant to be held without
bond.
Ebner said a high bond was necessary due to
Fuentes being a possible flight risk and for
the safety of the child.
The bond was set at $2 million and it is unclear
whether the individual would be able to make
that bond.
So a few different things here.
Number one, undocumented poop.
That's a perk up word for Fox News.
Fox News suddenly cares about the story again.
When it was the rape of a ten year old with
a pregnancy but unable to get an abortion,
the story might be fake and it was not an
interesting story.
All of a sudden, now that the perpetrator,
the believed perpetrator who has allegedly
confessed and whose guilt may be proven by
DNA very soon is undocumented.
Now they care about the story, but they're
spinning it.
And we'll talk about that in the next segment.
Now, of course, if there's a DNA match, this
is going to be an open and shut case.
And we will soon know that many of you emailing
me saying, if there isn't a case that requires
no bond, wouldn't it be this one?
Because isn't the individual, if indeed he
is an undocumented immigrant, potentially
a flight risk to get out of the country?
I think that that's absolutely true.
And it's weird to me that that bond was granted.
That being said, we don't know the financial
situation of this individual.
$2 million bond may be an impossibility.
And even if you have to come up with 10% with
a bail bondsman, 200,000 may be an impossibility.
We just don't know.
It may effectively be no bond.
Don't know the answer to that.
One other aspect to this.
Very often in child rape cases, I get e-mails
from people in the audience saying, I can't
wait for this guy to end up in prison, where,
you know, they'll often say something like
where Bubba is going to give this guy an even
stricter punishment than the time in prison.
Talking, of course, about prison rape.
I've said this before and I will say it again.
No matter how vile the crime and no matter
how strict the sentence, which this is a very
serious alleged crime, and the sentence should
be very severe.
The the counting on the lack of security in
our prisons so that people also are raped
as part of an additional punishment, I think
is absolutely disgusting when and I'm not
denying that it happens.
But when people say, you know, child molesters
have it tough in prison, they're going to
end up rape themselves.
And I like that.
We have a problem in American prisons that
they are unable to keep inmates safe.
It should.
If you believe there should be stricter punishments
for certain crimes.
Well, we can lobby for them.
We can we can vote, we can find elected officials
or whatever.
That will change the law to make the punishment
stricter.
But relishing off the record, punishments
that are the result of faulty prisons that
aren't able to protect inmates like, for example,
prison rape of child molester.
It's very hard for me to say that that that's
a good thing or the punishment should be that
doled out by the justice system.
And if this person is indeed the perpetrator,
it should be a very severe punishment.
But the relishing the prison rape stuff hard
for me to get behind that.
Okay.
So that's the update on the story.
Let's now go to the right wing reaction.